I mean on a day like today it looks so
adil ik Astley beautiful just hope it is
in the future
at least there's still some life here in
the Thames you just worry in a hundred
hundred and fifty years time what it's
going to look like yeah the thing is if
you look closely we're all desensitized
to it but if you do look it's just tons
of rubbish floating paths it's when you
actually sit here and open your eyes and
look that you realize every single thing
we've got here it's horrifying
Marshall the alternative is they I mean
you know it's just part of our lives
nowadays I went to Mumbai and I saw for
myself how dreadful
the problem is we just got everything
from food wrappers look at this a coat
hanger and within my lifetime all 19
beaches there are completely out of
bounds toxic noxious because of the
plastic reality is it's convenient this
was all easily scooped up at a
supermarket popped in a bag and we came
straight here if I'd have been at home
preparing it all maybe we could have
used less plastic when it comes to
little ones nappies these are so Hardy
they're so absorbent they last all night
and well we still wanted to get through
about seven of them a day and I do feel
guilty about all the plastic that's
involved the other component of course
the wet wipes these are the ones that we
choose to use they don't say on them
flush down the loo but we know and that
these are creating havoc with the
environment particularly with river beds
the River Thames there's only a couple
of hundred meters away and well we're
told by experts that they're changing
the shape of the river beds because
there's so much plastic in them but
there's nothing better than a wet wipe
to get rid of mess on a baby's bottom
you throw it in so this is just
literally seven days everything that
we've used that's plastic
normally we're quite good at recycling
aren't we but we haven't separated it
out and
it's actually horrifying
we don't know works gang we don't know
what's happening to it and then stuff
like this does it just end up in the
ground does it end up being burned does
it end up in the oceans exactly and
that's the fear well I hope that over
the next two weeks by at least trying
our very best to cut out single-use
plastic this bin doesn't get even half
full but oh it's not going to be easy